yeah how's Canada Canada's fun Canada's
chill I mean I you know we went skiing
in so much Whistler right yeah in
Vancouver yeah as every good white
person does uh on vacation I went skiing
I'm now kidding uh it was good it's fine
uh it's just like busy it's a very
popular place to go yeah I guess I know
have you ever been skiing uh it's fine
it's fun I like it it's fun yeah trying
to think about how to describe it like
it was just very standard because I mean
I I wasn't really going what I could do
four questions what was the better
experience skiing or Avatar I'm selling
this property skiing okay good selling
this experience uh Connor's just like
yes
I mainly went uh for as you should see
my family because my you know uh my uh
one of my brothers works out there and
uh I just wanted to spend time with my
family because I haven't seen my older
brother in like five years damn and then
spent Christmas with my whole family
together in like five years so I was
like okay yeah sure when they wanted to
go out to Canada I was like yeah sure
even though I've spent most of this
goddamn year in North America yeah I was
like sure let's go Canada let's go again
yeah yeah I like kind of the shell kind
of this fun uh Canada's like a really
nice place everyone's nice uh it was
just like when I arrived in Vancouver it
was like a crazy snowstorm and so like
yeah it was insane yeah Aki's uh Aki's
flight got delayed a day because
apparently like all of like the North
and like East Coast were just having
these like horror like blizzards I think
when I flew in it was like uh at least
half the flights to Vancouver have been
like canceled yeah uh but for me I was
like dude like nothing like yeah nothing
got to the airport I was like damn it's
dead no one's here and I was like I say
weave through it all it's crazy I was
super super easy oh man Canadian
immigration people are so much more
chill than American ones that's for sure
they are they're like so what you do and
I'm like skiing they're like have a
great have a good one and I was like oh
this is right meanwhile us would be like
where exactly are you staying what's
your middle name what's your family
what's your mom's maiden name like
what's the like circumference of your
ball sack we need to know tell me your
entire family tree right now give me a
review of Avatar 2 right now I think
because when I went with uh when I went
to the US in December with Pete I think
yeah try to crack a few jokes Pete's
American yeah he was cracking a few
jokes the immigration people and they
were just like no don't but he's
American it's like not not right now I'm
sorry I have to stop you but shut the
[ __ ] up
I mean Kevin is nice and Canada's just
chill I mean they literally just all I
did was maybe like okay one day I might
go skiing and then my family and then
yeah next I would just do nothing and
just chill I've actually never been to
that side of Canada I've never been to
the Vancouver side like I've I've like
gone like you know uh laid over and
stuff like that over airport but like
I've never been outside I've heard
Vancouver is a very nice city it feels
like Seattle but more Canadian right
it's very like probably because it is
it's very geographically very close yeah
but it had similar Vibes to uh Seattle I
think I prefer the uh east coast of
Canada
to like New Brunswick before and that
was kind of more chill felt I feel like
Vancouver doesn't feel very
stereotypically Canadian right in a
sense just feels like a more like a
North American city with a Sprinkle of
Canada a little sprinkle of Canada
sprinkler Canada uh it was fine I mean I
didn't spend that much uh time in
Vancouver actually I dude I there's I
when we're looking at places to eat it
was like all Japanese and Korean and
Chinese restaurants really yeah because
I think there's a giant Asian population
yeah
there's a giant Asian population massive
massive and yeah dude the lines for all
the ramen shops were insane like loads
did you eat anything wrong I had I had
no it was um
um
all the ramen yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
better chain they have one in Vancouver
they had one in Vancouver and I was like
because I was with my family and they
were like we'd like to try it and I was
like all right well I'm flying back to
Japan tomorrow but I I'll never say no
to some Ramen and it seemed like it was
like I mean it was a Japanese chain so I
thought that's pretty legit yeah it was
pretty good I'd say it was probably just
as good as most Japanese ramen honestly
okay I think a lot of people like to
pretend that Ramen is some kind of Godly
thing here but honestly like I feel like
no it's it's it's literally junk food
yeah it's it's really like if you have
the ingredients it's kind of hard to
[ __ ] it up it's like the cheapest meal
you can get here yeah it's like yeah
sure there are some amazing ones in
Japan it's like a bog standard Ramen you
get in Japan like it isn't especially
people making out to be yeah
um and so yeah it was fine it was good
and all the staff spoke Japanese so I
was like I was like me me I mean I got
this i got this I think they were like
what the [ __ ] when I started speaking
yeah when you boss it up
I'll take Ramen
they were pretty chill about it they
just didn't even bet a knife and I was
like I wouldn't Japanese my family like
whoa It's almost like you've been living
in Japan
you could do that and I was like well
yeah I mean I guess I can order food
like yeah
he's like yo he's fluent in Japanese
how'd you say this in Japanese yeah how
would you say that in Japanese I was I
was there and I was like I swear I was
like Canadian Matt Stone he'd come in
opposite me bro this guy ordered three
Romans to himself and ate them what yeah
it was insane like like stand full bowls
of ramen I was like I was eating my rum
and I was like what the [ __ ]
I was getting so distracted by this guy
I felt bad I was like staring at him
because I was like how is that was this
guy I'm surprised your competitiveness
didn't kick in Billy us dude I realized
I was struggling to eat my large-sized
Ramen I I regretted getting the lodge
but it's decent yeah I mean Canadian
food is um
it's an American food kind of they don't
I mean I guess on that side of America
right yes very Americanized stuff I mean
I had poutine obviously I mean I even
though poutine meets the hype because oh
[ __ ] no we have that in the UK it's
literally called chips cheese and gravy
yeah pretend like it's different but
it's literally not we came before you
don't [ __ ] try and take ourselves you
can you can put a name on it we
literally had that we've always had that
in the UK it's it's it's just because it
has like a [ __ ] French name there it
sounds like yeah a Cuisine yeah we've
had dish every single chip shop in like
the north UK does this and and it tastes
no different I don't care what they say
it literally tastes but there's one
issue with that you have to go to the
north yeah yeah
thank you for seeing you Joey thank you
for using it just like no if you care
all right I will say in occasional
restaurants you can get like fancier
versions that are pretty good yeah we
had a fancy ones we were in Toronto
good snack foods that's fine I'm not
gonna be like hey dog get in here you
gotta try this like yeah one but it felt
like it was okay this is uh this is like
junk food it's it's like a comfort junk
food yeah and you've just prettied it up
a bit you know I just you know it's it's
like serving bangers and mash or
something and you know it's it's there's
only so much you can do with like
bangers and match right but at the end
of the day it's just some sausages a bit
of gravy and some uh some [ __ ] um
maybe that's what you guys need to start
doing instead of calling it something
like unattractive like bangers and mash
give it like a fancy name we need some
more [ __ ] I don't know what you're
talking about that's [ __ ] hot I don't
know man we need some more [ __ ]
French names man I've ever done the
French name something it just
automatically sounds it's called like
it's like oh [ __ ] you can charge ten
times the amount exactly [ __ ] thing
big brain like why are we calling it
like [ __ ] milk call it like
liquidity it's like [ __ ] 15 or
something obviously we're full in French
as you can tell
yeah exactly there's a reason why they
call it omelette do formage instead of
cheese omelette yeah you know it's just
like it just sounds a little fancy it's
like oh okay or a fancy boy right
speaking a whole another language God
damn all right you know what memes I'm
really glad made a comeback Zoolander
memes oh
oh yeah yeah they're like they're back
in man it's so good that's so good
that's so funny that's a movie I've won
a free watching that's been my highlight
of the end of 2022 yeah
I recommended and they're all bangers
they're all so good that's bangers and
mash right
all I did all uh you know because I was
with my family and obviously my family
just want to have drinks every night so
yeah I came back and I was like please
no more drinks no but that's just like
every holiday in England oh for sure I'm
not sure about America but uh you just
eat a [ __ ] on and you drink a [ __ ] ton
um and that's basically what I did for
my holiday I gained a lot of weight that
I'm I'm back on that [ __ ] salad diet
guys I see on the contrary I lost a lot
of weight because I was drinking nothing
but pocar sweat for five years
I wanted to lose the weight but I was
like not like this this is probably the
worst way to do it